uh so you've presented teslabot as
primarily useful in the factory first of
all i think humanoid robots are
incredible from a fan of robotics i
think
uh the elegance of movement that cuba um
the humanoid robots that bipedal robots
show are just so cool so it's uh really
interesting that you're working on this
and also talking about applying the same
kind of all the ideas of some of which
we've talked about with data engine all
the things that we're talking about with
tesla autopilot
just uh transferring that over to the
just yet another robotics problem
i have to ask since i care about human
robot interaction so the human side of
that so you've talked about mostly in
the factory do you see it uh also do you
see part of this problem that teslabot
has to solve is interacting with humans
and potentially having a place like in
the home
so interacting not just sure not
replacing labor but also like
i don't know
being a friend or an assistant yeah i
think the possibilities are
you know endless
yeah it's it's obviously like a
it's not quite in tesla's
primary mission direction of
accelerating sustainable energy but
uh it is a
an extremely useful thing that we can do
for the world which is to make a useful
humanoid robot
um that is capable of
interacting with the world and
um
helping in in many different ways uh so
certainly in fact reason and really just
just i mean i think if you say like
uh
extrapolate to you know many years in
the future it's like
i i think
uh work will become optional
so
like there's a lot of jobs that
if you if
people weren't paid to do it
they wouldn't do it like it's not it's
not fun you know necessarily like
if you're washing dishes all day it's
like uh you know
even if you really like washing dishes
you really want to do it for eight hours
a day every day probably not so
um and then there's like dangerous work
and basically if it's dangerous boring
uh it has like potential for repetitive
stress injury that kind of thing um
then that's really where
human right robots would add the most
value initially
um so that's
what we're aiming for is is to um
for the humor to drove us to do jobs
that people don't don't voluntarily want
to do
um
and then we'll have to pair that
obviously with some kind of universal
base basic income in the future
so
i think um
so do you see a world when there's like
hundreds of millions of tesla bots
doing different performing different
tasks throughout the world
yeah i haven't really thought about it
that far into the future but i guess
that there may be something like that um
so
ask a wild question so
the the number of tesla cars has been
accelerating there's been
close to 2 million produced many of them
have autopilot
i think we're over 2 million now yeah do
you think there will ever be a time when
there will be more tesla bots
than tesla cars
yeah i i i
you know actually it's funny you asked
this question because normally i do try
to think
pretty far into the future but i haven't
really thought that far into the future
with the with the
tesla bot or it's code named optimus i i
call it optimus sub prime
because that's not it's not like a giant
you know transformer robot um
so
uh
but it's meant to be a general purpose
health health robot
um
and and basically like like the things
that were basically
like like tesla
i think um is the has the most advanced
real world ai
uh for interacting with the real world
which we developed as a function of
to make self-driving work
um and so
along with custom hardware and
like a lot of
you know uh hardcore low-level software
to have it run efficiently and be you
know power efficient because because you
know it's one thing to do neural nets if
you've got a gigantic server room with
ten thousand computers but now let's say
you just you have to now distill that
down into
one computer that's running at low power
in a humanoid robot or a car
um that's actually very difficult a lot
of hardcore software work is required
for that
um
so
so since we're kind of like solving the
navigate the real world
with neural nets problem for
cars which are kind of like robots with
four wheels then it's like kind of a
natural extension of that is to
put it in a robot with arms and legs
uh
and actually you know actuators um
so
[Music]
um
like like the the two
like the hard things are like you
basically need to make the
have the role of be intelligent enough
to interact in a sensible way with the
environment
um
so you need real real world ai and you
need
to be very good at
manufacturing which is a very hard
problem tails is very good at
manufacturing and also uh has the real
world ai so
making the humanoid robot work is
uh basically it means developing
custom uh motors and sensors
uh
that that are different from what a car
would use
um
but we we're also we have
i think with the the best expertise in
developing advanced electric motors and
power electronics so
it just has to be for
a humored robot application not a car
still you do talk about love sometimes
so let me ask this isn't like for like
sex robots or something like that's the
answer
yes
uh
there is something compelling
to us not compelling but we connect with
the
humanoid robots or even leg of robots
like with the dog in shapes with dogs
it just it seems like you know there's a
huge amount of loneliness in this world
all of us seek companionship and with
other humans friendship and all those
kinds of things we have a lot of here in
austin a lot of people have dogs
there seems to be a huge opportunity to
also have robots that decrease
the uh
the amount of loneliness in the world or
help us humans connect with each with
each other
so in a way that dogs can
um do you think about that who tests
about it all or is it really focused on
the problem of
of performing specific tasks not
connecting with humans
um
i mean to be honest i have not actually
thought about it from the companionship
standpoint but i think it actually would
end up being it could be actually a very
good companion
and and
it could
you develop like a personality
uh
over time that is that is like
unique like uh you know it's not like
they're just all the robots are the same
and that personality could evolve
to be you know uh
match match the the the owner or the you
know or i guess
the owner uh well
whatever you want to call it uh the
other companions the other half right uh
the same way their friends do see i
think that's a huge opportunity i think
yeah no that's interesting
like um
the
because you know like there's a japanese
phrase i like the uh
wabi-sabi you know uh the subtle
imperfections
are what makes something special
and the subtle imperfections of the
personality of the robot
mapped to the subtle imperfections of
the robot's human
friend i don't know owner sounds like
maybe the wrong word but
um
could actually make an incredible buddy
basically in in that way the imperfect
r2d2 or like a c-3po sort of thing you
know so from a machine learning
perspective
i think the flaws
being a feature is really nice you could
be quite terrible at being a robot for
quite a while
in the general home environment or all
the in general world and that's kind of
adorable and that's like those are your
flaws and you fall in love with those
flaws so it's it's
very different than autonomous driving
where it's a very high stakes
environment you cannot mess up and so
yeah yeah it's more fun to be a robot in
the home
yeah in fact if you think of like c-3po
and
r2d2 yeah like they actually had a lot
of like flaws and imperfections and
silly things and they would argue with
each other
and um were they actually good at doing
anything
i'm not exactly sure
they definitely added a lot to the story
um
but but they're they're sort of quirky
elements and
you know
that they would like make mistakes and
do things like it was like uh it made
them
relatable i don't know um
endearing
so
so yeah i think that that could be
something that uh probably would happen
um
but our initial focus is just to make it
useful uh so that so
um
i'm confident we'll get it done i'm not
sure what the exact time frame is but uh
like we'll probably have i don't know
a decent prototype
towards the end of next year or
something like that
and it's cool that it's connected to
tesla the car
the so so yeah
it's using a lot of you know it would
use the autopilot inference computer and
um a lot of the training that we've done
for the four cars in terms of
recognizing
real world things could be applied
directly to the
to the robot um
so it's but but there's there's a lot of
custom actuators and sensors that need
to be developed
and an extra module on top of the vector
space
uh for love
uh yeah that's me
okay
that's true
um
that could be useful in all environments
like you said a lot of people argue in
the car so maybe we can help them out
you